head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard
charts because we have this story from
the Daily Mail Rudy Giuliani has to pay
Georgia election workers
$148 million for accusing them of
helping steal the 2020 race America's
mayor faces Financial ruin over huge
damages in defamation case like how is
$148 million reasonable they're saying
it's 75 imp punitive damages 20 uh each
for emotional distress 16 for Freeman 17
for Moss for damage to their reputations
you kidding me man I get the famed every
single day and I can't get a single
penny out of these you ever heard of any
of these people by the way of course not
you know this is this is sadly how this
goes and and juliani is not going to be
the last person and I talked to some of
Trump's lawyers about this too because
people
they don't seem to understand the true
nature of the political world that we
exist in until they reach certain levels
right and so when they came after
Infowars for censorship and I mean what
was the number they hit Alex with like
oh we're suing Alex for3 trillion the
GDP of France 1.6 billion or something
no no no they wanted the GDP of France
it was a trillion dollars and they had
some formula that they worked this up
but my my point is this and I told was
three trillion I told some of this to
Trump's lawyers cuz they don't seem to
get it they're like oh well this is
great that we get to go to court now
because now we're going to get to show
the evidence and prove our case uh no
you're not the judge is going to shut
you down not let you show any evidence
and just rule against you and they say
well that's not how the legal system
works okay fine find out the hard way
for yourself and now Trump's lawyers are
finding that they think we're going to
present all this evidence to the court
and now they're like nope you can't
present any of that evidence say what
the heck3 trillion were the penalties
that Jones was facing that is more than
the GDP of France so my point is is that
this is it's it's rare air or it used to
be rare air for you to get these rulings
and these court cases against you it's
going to become ever more present now
just like with censorship they test it
on one person and then they go after
everybody else Rudy Giuliani will not be
the last person that gets hundred
million judgments against him other
Trump attorneys will get it other Trump
Associates will get it and they're just
never going to stop the the justice
system is completely out of control I I
don't think people have really they
haven't grasped just how corrupted and
out of control it is and unfortunately
it's going to have to hit them just like
with Trump's lawyers oh we'll present
the and it will and it will it
absolutely will because I've been saying
this for a long time there there are so
many people who think if I just turn my
lights off and hide under the covers the
angry mob that's going door too smashing
everything will skip over my house no it
won't so here's a guy sitting in front
of me Owen who yelled some things on a
bullhorn and they try and they literally
use that in s sentencing documents the
speech you made tell them my dirty
speech Tim tell them my dirty speech
well it was not just what you said on on
the on the on the on the grounds it was
what you said later on on your show and
before too and before that had nothing
to do with what happened that day and I
believe correct me if I'm wrong us had a
permit for the protest yeah we pered
rally we had a stage that was um back
behind I think it was on the northeast
side of the capital we had a stage set
up we were going to be speaking I was
one of the speakers they were other big
speakers they were going to be a part of
that and and we were going from the
Ellipsis from Trump spe to our speaking
stage that was our route and when we saw
all the chaos at the capital we said hey
we got to stop this so we got on Horns
to try to stop it that's all on video we
talked to the Capitol Police and said
hey what can we do we want to work with
you to try to stop this that's all on
video as well the government even
acknowledges this in their sentencing
memo against me that I didn't go in and
that I did try to stop it and I did say
we were there to be peaceful but the
higher up said no you're still going to
make an example out of Shroyer but you
know I I think we can we can get into my
personal case Tim if we want but here's
here's the larger picture that that
needs to be understood and this goes
beyond just the realm of the political
world there is no incentive for justice
in our justice system whatsoever the
incentive from the US attorneys and the
prosecuting attorneys is convictions
that's their incentive they overcharge
you drastically hoping or assuming
they're going to get a plea out of you
which most of the time they do so they
keep their conviction rates High 9899
100% so they think they get a better job
climb the ladder their incentive is
convictions not Justice then you have
the bench the judge their incentive is
imprisonment got to fill the prisons got
to prove you're going to put the bad
guys away Justice never comes into the
frame here Justice is never even
entering into the conversation and let
me tell you from from somebody who's
been there there's there's three tables
here there's the judge's bench there's
the prosecuting attorney and then
there's you and until you've sat in that
corner and you've w witness this be done
to you and you've sat there and watched
a judge and a prosecuting attorney sit
there and never even consider Justice
the feeling of of loneliness and
isolation when you realize there is no
justice here Justice was never the
concern the concern from the attorneys
was conviction and the concern from the
judge was imprisonment you never had a
shot there is no justice in the justice
system anymore I don't know what can be
done about this I I really I mean
something has to change the first thing
we need to consider is Donald Trump
being elected next year and then we'll
see how things go when did things change
in the justice system are you guys
familiar with change like when did it
become pretty corrupt for a very long
time been like that forever I mean I
don't think probably whole Liv 100% like
that's been what it is I think it's just
more blatant in that you know look the
left plays to win I may I make this
point all the time and this is I think
why they're able to get the dubs it is
that they're able to get because they
rely upon the people on the other side
even if it's like whether they're Center
or the right or whatever it is that you
want to call them where you still kind
of have some sort of belief some sort of
there some sanctity in sort of these
institutions whether it be from the
police officers on up to the
prosecutions like this is the way we do
thing and at the end of the day um Ms
will prevail um justice will prevail and
that's just not that to be fair has
never been the reality obviously you
being in in the situation it is that you
you've been you've seen it sort of
firsthand it's like
nobody's coming to save me and all of
these guys are against me like it the
system is is literally rigged against
you and especially when you're dealing
with immoral people that have absolutely
no problem with weaponizing that
institution against you it's a soulless
thing it's like they're sess it's a it's
a very difficult like enemy to to fight
I always use this analogy people that
watch me know I use this all the time
it's like you're going into a boxing
ring right and you're entering it in and
that the person on the opposite side of
you that you're supposed to be fighting
1 V one has already told you look my
gloves are loaded I've bought off the
judges I bought off the Riff and I'm
about to cheat and what the Instinct of
the non- leftist is to still go into it
with fairness because we look at it like
well this is this is how we're supposed
to Echo we don't want to be like the
enemy the problem is is that the enemy
has no problem kicking you in in in the
you know midsection they have no issues
with doing that so that's a harsh
reality that we all kind of have to have
to face but I think once more people
realize that we can actually start to
come up with some sort of solution and
some sort of plan attack of attack but
people need to realize that this is how
the justice system is aligned this is
the way that it is sort of rigged um
against you from the prosecution on up
and on on down it's not there to serve
Justice it's not there to sort of reach
some sort of conclusion that is supposed
to be the the just one that's not the
way that it is designed well this is why
I think Viv Ramis Swami's campaign is
actually the most important camp
campaign right now even more so than
Donald Trump's because you know the
right-wing has always had this weird and
it and it kind of deals with they want
to support law enforcement but
supporting law enforcement or police and
wanting Justice uh you know reform
justice system reform and prison reform
need to be two completely separate
issues they need to be two completely
separate issues and conservatives need
to get this and that's why viam and
Swami really going hard against the
federal establishment is so important
because this is a winning issue
and what conservatives need to realize
is that Justice Reform is a winning
issue you will win I mean I don't want
to get too politically wonky here but
it's an issue that they've let the left
dominate they've let the Democrats
dominate for so long and and it's time
for them to get in there and Viv I think
presents it really well and and I mean I
I still suspect Donald Trump gets the
nomination if he wins I hope he makes VI
in charge of some special committee or
something to just completely abolish
like 95% of these Federal institutions
that are so corrupted conservatives and
Republican politicians need to stop
being afraid of their own
shadow there you you know you're the
side of law enforcement that's fine but
Justice Reform and prison reform are
completely separate issues and it's a
winning issue you will win a lot of
votes if you can properly verbalize and
vocalize how you will attack these
issues I think like VI ramaswami has
done what kind of prison reform do you
suggest well I'll put it to you like
this cuz it's very complex and I could
go on forever based of off what I've
learned from the top to the bottom here
but I I'll I'll try to put it simply
when I was in prison the Bureau of
Prisons had a hearing in front of
Congress where my name got brought up by
by Matt Gates thank goodness and they
were asking for $2 billion so they want
two billion more dollars because they
have staff problems and they have
infrastructure problems and believe me
they do uh I'm showering in showers that
have black mold in them I'm dealing with
staff in the prisons that I mean they Lo
they lost like $22,000 worth of my
property I mean I can go on and on and
on so the issues are real but we all
know if they put 2,000 excuse me $2
billion dollar more into the Bureau of
Prisons do you think that's going to
improve a damn thing no it's not going
to improve a damn thing so what needs to
be done if they need2 billion more
dollars annually what they need to do is
a little math find out what annually how
many prisoners annually equals to $2
billion and release them all tomorrow
release every single one of them all
tomorrow there should not be a single
nonviolent criminal in prison that's our
problem here and maybe that's kind of
the springboard for the political
argument if if if if any Republican has
the courage to do it like VI the
springboards needs to be no no
nonviolent criminals belong in jail I
mean really what you have here sure you
can have house arrest you can have the
ankle monitor I mean I would say it like
this cuz people always ask well what is
it like in there what is it like in
there we'll do a little Camala Harris
Vin diagram I would say take a VIN
diagram three circles you've got um a
daycare center right here you've got an
old folks home right here and then You'
got a concentration camp right here and
then all the things that they have in
similar boom that's that's what the
federal system is like most I mean most
Knights there it's just a bunch of it's
just a bunch of old men watching TV I
mean that's it that's it they're just
sitting around watching TV a lot of
these guys have kids they're fathers and
they're never going to see their kids
again and they're just sitting around
watching TV wasting their time way they
could be doing that so it's it's really
a dramatic issue that until you've seen
it firsthand it it's really hard to
understand but I've seen it firsthand $2
billion worth of prisoners release him
from the jail tomorrow there's your $2
billion that you I mean we have more
prisoners here than we do in China and
and Russia it it's also important to
know that what you I don't know if I
don't know if China's numbers are really
a
docent good point they also disappear
and they you know they're never found
again but and then there's a lot of
organ there's a lot of organs also found
there that are readily available but
that's a different story but but good
point I definitely agree with you but
you brought up a kind of a an
anarchistic libertarian perspective no
victim no crime a lot of people on the
right are saying we got to back to Blue
no matter what we got to back the police
officers the police officers saying I
don't care what laws they're going to
make up I'm going to enforce them to the
fullest extent that I can happily and
we've seen a huge transition from from
actual criminals going to jail to now
political thought criminals going to
jail which is absolutely crazy it needs
to be addressed in a way because you you
you kind of described it as soulless
there is a lot of soullessness there is
a lot of people who are just like I'm
just doing my job there are a lot of
Kamala harrises that believe that they
have to make their way up have to of
course make their career by putting
innocent people behind bars which she
did extensively especially when it came
to things like marijuana which is
absolutely freaking ridiculous so yeah I
I agree with you on those larger kind of
libertarian sentiments I think they
would help ganize the base and I think
the people who are rooting for back the
blue are essentially rooting for the
their own enslavement and imprisonment
and maybe the selling point to
conservatives or Republicans that that
are too afraid to do that say well I'll
tell you what if you don't if you don't
have Criminal Justice Reform or prison
reform well then you're going to end up
in prison very soon so there's a
difference between victimless crime and
nonviolent crime like um like Financial
crimes like what Sam bankman freed is
allegedly done or maybe he's been
convicted of it so like do you also
encourage like you said nonviolent like
like highlevel um Financial criminals do
you think they should be let out is
there a victim so nothing is there would
be in that
Cas hold on I I believe the purpose of
prison for the most part is to take
someone who is dangerous and make sure
they can't hurt people so for for SBF
the real uh P penalty should be house
arrest with restrictions meaning you
can't do Financial work you can't you
can't trade on these platforms you are
being removed from the area which and
where you did these crimes You could
argue that stealing a bunch of people's
money makes it so they can't buy food
and then they starve to death which is
like a violent act but the point is this
did this guy go around like mercilessly
beating children there's like there's
the overt attack violence but then
there's also the stealing the resource
irrelevant but but think so jail
supposed to rehabilitate people it
doesn't do any of that it makes them
worse CRI there's two philosophies in in
the prison system there's Rehabilitation
or punishment right retribution but but
see I think where you're going to
nothing is black and white right
obviously nothing is black and white and
I think Tim you know you propose a idea
like if you if you go into a smash and
grab that's a violent crime if you steal
if you steal from somebody and that
takes food off their table You could
argue that that's a violent crime
Financial crimes like SPF I think that
you could reasonably argue okay you're
going to be maybe on house arrest but
more importantly every Financial
activity that you make is now going to
be monitored I mean it's not that hard
to do here's what I'd say SBF there is
zero risk of him punching a kid in the
face so we don't have to worry about
locking him up behind multiple razor
wire fences cuz he's not in he all we
have to worry about is we don't want
this guy doing Financial deals and
trading because that's where he broke
the law in fact I don't even know what
house arrest does I would say house
arrest because we do want some punitive
element of this short duration maybe a
couple years and then after that it's
restrictions on access to financial
systems and services he should be able
to live and work but he's going to be
breaking rocks or working at a grocery
store he's not going to be doing big
deals now if a guy robbed a liquor store
this guy's dangerous armed robbery okay
we remove this guy from society
temporarily and tell them you are a
danger to people so we're putting you in
a box if if someone is not if there is
no victim or if it's non-violent then
you're then we do not need prison so uh
victimless crimes means like somebody
was found with pot I I don't see how
locking that person up in prison solves
any problem I agree on the victimless
crimes that people can be better served
by learning I mean what would be a
better what do you think for like
someone caught with a bunch of pot
nothing the War on Drugs the War on
Drugs needs to end tomorrow uh the cop
can say oh pardon me sir I I wasted your
time yeah if you're going to go after
the pot dealers you got to go after a
big Pharma right see but see now now
this is an important Point what I
learned being in there I'm not the only
political prisoner in there now in the
political sphere of media
yes people that get arrested for dealing
drugs in my opinion are political
prisoners if they worked for a pharmacy
or if they worked for a big
pharmaceutical company you can you can
deal drugs all freaking day long and you
can make billions of dollars doesn't
matter how many people
die yeah but if you deal fitel you're
going to jail forever now I'm not
endorsing this is no way shape or form
an endorsement of drug use it's bad for
you but those are political prisoners in
my eyes too thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00. M and become a member over at
timcast.net